Russia has accused the Ukrainian
military of deliberately attacking a
hospital in a russian-held area of
eastern Ukraine in what it said was a
war crime that killed 14 people some
footage has been provided by Russian TV
Sky News has geolocated the hospital but
hasn't verified the date the footage was
taken or the circumstances surrounding
it Ukraine has not yet responded to the
accusation
for a closer look at what's happening on
the ground is former military
intelligence security officer Philipp
Ingram
well the Russian claims about the attack
on that hospital are almost certainly
disinformation it's something that they
focus on a lot but looking down in the
front line we've got activity the whole
way down the front line where Russian
forces are probing out they've been in
this operation area uh they're looking
around bakmut
um and they're trying to stop the
ukrainians coming forward and harking
looking for those sorts of weak points
um from a bigger picture from belarusa
we've got the elements of the second
motor rifle division has moved on into
the lashank OR blast in preparation for
spring counter-offensives that we keep
talking about looking at those
counteroffensives and the options in a
little bit more detail there are really
two areas that the Russians could be
attacking through the first one is down
through the village of volidar that we
can see through here with a large sweep
if they move the second motor rifle
division down there they're probing into
that sort of area at the moment but the
other area which is probably the more
likely is if they get some success in
the back mode area where the fighting's
been going on for the last six months
the ukrainians have been holding them in
place that allows the ukrainians then to
get their troops out and to go on train
on Western Equipment but that's going to
be the center of attention for the
coming weeks and months